حديثي لكم ايها الاخوه
الاحبه هو
حديث لرحله
كفاح لتجربه
حياه تجربه
حياه
لرجل عاش اول حياته منذ
الطفوله يعمل في مطعم ابيه يغسل الصحون
ويكنس
الارض ومع ذلك كان يتعلم في
المدرسه وانتهى به المطاف الى ان يصير
نائبا لرئيس جامعه
[تصفيق]
حضرموت ورئيسا لتحرير مجلتها العلميه
المحكمه حياتي
الاولى حياه يسيره بسيطه ملها كفاح
ومعاناه وتعب
وشقاه كنت احمل كراسات المدرسه الى المطعم
وانا اشتغل عندما
اشكو عندما اشكو الى ابي التعب تعب العمل
في
المطعم كان يحثني على
الصبر لانني مضطر الى ان اساعده فانا اكبر
اخوتي الاشقاء
وكان يقول لي عباره ما زالت ترن في اذني
الى اليوم رحمه الله عليه يقول لي يا ابني
تعلم وانا اريدك ان تتعلم حتى تنفع نفسك
وابنائك عندما تكبر
لكن صنعه في اليد امان من
الفقر والله هذه الكلمه تركت اثرا في نفسي
صنعه في اليد امان من الفقر اكتسبت الصنعه
وصرت طباخا محترفا
فوالله الذي لا اله الا هو ان الجاني
الدهر الى هذه المهنه لاعود اليها
[تصفيق]
اليوم اقولها غير مستنكف
عنها عشت حياتي هذه بتعبها بعناها بكد
بقائها اكملت الابتدائيه فال المتوسطه
وانا اعمل في المطعم صرت مساعدا لطباخ
دخلت دار المعلمين وهي بمستوى الثانويه
الت خرجوها يعملون معلمين صرت طباخا
محترفا وانا اعمل هنا وادرس
هناك عينت معلما عام
7 في مديريه دوعن مكثت بها ثلاث سنوات مدر
في المرحله الابتدائيه ادرس كل المواد
اللغه العربيه والتربيه الاسلاميه
والتربيه الوطنيه والجغرافيه والتاريخ شان
كل المعلمين الذين
يعلمون الصفوف الصغرى في مدارس التعليم
العام
كلفت في السنه الثانيه ل ان ادرس الصف
الثاني الاعدادي الصف
الثامن لا قدره لي على تدريس هذا الصف رس
ماده اللغه العربيه لان استاذ الماده
استاذ الماده
سافر وليس عندهم احد غيري
يدرس في منتصف العام دخلت القاعه ادرس
الطلاب درسا سالني احد الطلاب سؤالا يريد
ان
يمتحني فشلت في الاجابه عن
سؤاله
تلعثمت احس الطالب
بحرج فقال يا استاذ الجواب هو
كذا اراد ان يختبرني في اول حصه دخلت
فيها خرجت مهموما
مكتئبا فاحتضن ني رجل عليه رحمه الله
الشيخ عوض ب مهدي من مدينه الغيل كان يدرس
معنا في المدرسه راني مهموما حكيت له ما
جرى فاخذ
يهدئ من حزني والمي وقال لي هذا يحدث لكل
انسان في بدء حياته
العمليه اطمئنت اليه فكنت اتي اليه في
المساء لكي يعلمني الدرس الذي ادرسه في
اليوم الثاني للطلاب هذا علمني درسا ان
اخذ العلم من كل انسان لا يستكبر الانسان
في طلب العلم خذ العلم ممن هو اعلى منك
ومن هو في مستواك بل ان طالبك احيانا
يفيدك وتتعلم منه
اخذت على نفسي عهدا انلا اقف في مثل هذا
الموقف مره اخرى فان وقفت في هذا الموقف
مره اخرى فسات التدريس نهائيا واعود الى
المطعم بدات اهتم باللغه العربيه هذه
اللغه التي
قهرني سؤال طالب
فيها ذهبت اقرا
واقرا اخذت كتبا ونقلتها بيدي لم تكن هنا
في ذلك الوقت في سبعينيات القرن الماضي
الات
التصوير معلومات عندما تكتبها بيدك تثبت
في الذهن ومن هنا ظل ارتباطي باللغه
العربيه الى يومنا هذا عدت الى المكله
عملت بالتدريس في مدارسها سبع
سنوات وعدت للعمل في
المطام لاحت لي فرصه ان
ادرس في الجامعه
فرصه لكنها
مقرونه
بمشقه انا معلم واداره التربيه انذاك لم
تكن تفرغ للدراسه اذا علي ان التزم بتدريس
الطلاب ابي يحتاج الي لاعمل معه اذا لا
يمكن ان اتخلى عن مساعده ابي ولو تركت كل
شيء في
الدنيا هذه الفرصه ت
مني
التزاما وقفت هذا الموقف فعقدت العزم على
الله ان ادخل الكليه وان استعين
بالله هذه المرحله حتى عام 85 من عام 81
الى
85 كانت هذه المرحله هي اشق المراحل
بالنسبه لي
وتعبها كنت اخرج في الصباح الى الكليه
ادرس اعود الظهر الى المطعم اعجن نحو 30
كيلوغراما من من
الدقيق
واقطعها واذهب العصر
ادرس اعود المغرب الى المطعم الى الحاديه
عش
ليلا طبعا هذه مرحله صعبه جدا هناك
التزامات
للوظيفه حصص يجب ان تحضر كراسات طلاب يجب
ان
تصحح واجبات في الكليه يجب ان
تنفذ عمل في المطعم يجب ان
يؤدى صبرت
واحتملت وكنت الاول في
الدفعه عينت
معيدا فلح امامي امل اخر ان اكون استاذا
في الجامعه عينت بعيدا وانا اعمل في
المطعم طلابي الذين ادرسهم في الصباح
ياتون الى المطعم في المساء لياكل
عندي وهذا لا يخجلني
ابدا بل يزيدني شرفا لانني انحت في صخر
بعد هذا خف الحمل عني عندما عاد اخواي
الذان بعدي من اداء خدمه التجنيد وحمل عني
مؤونه العمل في المطعم ومساعده
ابي تعث للماجستير اكملته في الاردن اكملت
الدكتوراه في بغداد عدت الى الجامعه عينت
مساعدا لنائب رئيس الجامعه لشؤون الطلاب
غادرت الى الامارات عملت بها اربع سنوات
في فرع جامعه عجمان بابو ظبي عدت مره
اخرى الى المكل عينت يدا لكليه البنات
فريسا لتحرير مجله الجامعه المحكمه فنائب
لرئيس الجامعه لشؤون
الاكاديمي الذي يهمني من هذاه دروس
تعلمتها واريد ان اشير اليها بعبارات
موجزه لعل
طلابنا ياخذون منها
الفائده اذا اردت ان تنجح في امر
ما هناك محددات يجب ان تتبعها اولا ضع
لنفسك هدفا انا عندما احرجت في قاعه الدرس
قلت يجب ان اتعلم هذه اللغه ولو احرجت مره
اخرى لتركت العمل في التدريس وعدت الى
المطعم خلاص انتهى الامر بالنسبه لي عندما
لاحت لي فرصه الدراسه في الكليه اردت ان
احصل على شهاده اتخلص بها من العبء الذي
عليه عندما كنت الاول على الدفعه طمحت ان
اكون استاذا في الجامع ضع لنفسك هدفا
واستعن للوصول اليه بجمله من الامور اولها
الثقه
بالنفس كن واثقا من نفسك من
قدراتك الاستعانه
بالله اخلص النيه لله استعن به تضرع اليه
ان
يعينك حسن الظن بالله
ثق ان الله سيعينك وان يوفقك الله يقول في
الحديث القدسي انا عند حسن ظن عبدي
بي ان ظن بي خيرا فهو له وان ظن بي شرا
فهو له ظن بال خيرا الله لن يبخل
عليه استعن على
ذلك بامور
مهمه
الصبر والتحمل للمشاه الصبر ساعه الظرف
الذي اعاق اليوم احتمله واصبر فسين ازاح
عنك
غدا نظم
وقتك رتب
اولوياتك اليوم 24 ساعه كم ستنام
فيها خمس ساعات ست ساعات سبعه
ساعات بقي معك سب عشره ساعه ماذا تعمل
فيها اخرج منها ساعات للاكل والشرب
والصلاه رتب الاولويات انا عندما كنت اعمل
وادرس
واشتغل عندي امور لا يمكن ان ترحل تحضير
الحصه لا يمكن ان يرحل اذا يجب ان احضره
بعد ان اعود في المساء وان كنت
متعبا هناك امور يمكن ان ترحل قليلا الى
نهايه الاسبوع كتصحيح دفاتر الطلاب هناك
امور ممكن ان ترحل
اكثر شهر او اكثر من ذلك كنا كانت اجازه
نهايه الاسبوع عندنا يوما واحدا يوم
الجمعه فقط وليس يومين كما هو الحال الان
اذا
استفد من عطله نهايه الاسبوع من الاجازات
الرسميه دينيه كانت ام وطنيه وزع اعمالك
رتبها بحسب اولوياتها وافد من هذه
الاجازات حتى اليوم هذا افاد المطعم علمني
على فكره اشياء كثيره جدا لم تعلمها في
الجامعه اليوم بحكم الوظيفه انا ملزم
بدوام يومي في مكتبي بريد يومي يجب ان
يوقع ويراجع هناك التزمات اكاديميه تيس
طلاب في الجامعه
بحوث طلاب تشرف عليها رسائل ماجستير
ودكتوراه تشرف عليها رسائل ماجستير
ودكتورات تناقشها بحوث ترقيات علميه
تحكمها بحوث مقدمه للنشر في المجله اراس
تحريرها يجب ان تحكمها هذه كلها مهام يجب
ان تجدول عند التزام لصحيفه شعاع الامل
يجب ان اعد لهم حلقه شهريه هذه كلها
التزامات افادني المطعم انني
اجدول ارتبها بحسب اولويه ما يمكن ان يؤجل
يؤجل اذا نظم وقتك رتب اولوياتك افد من
اجازاتك ولا تهمل شيئا
منها شيء اخر مهم ربما يهمله كثير من
الناس انا من واقع
تجربتي رايته يفعل في الانسان فعل
سحر هو دعاء
الوالدين
بر
والديك
برهما يستجلب لك
دعائهما
ودعاهما يستجلب لك توفيق الله
لك صل
رحمك وبر الوالدين هو ارقى درجاتي صله
الرحم صل ارحامك الرسول عليه السلام
يقول من شاء ان يبسط له في رزقه وان ينسا
له في اثره يعني يطال في عمره فليص رحمه
دعوات ربما تلقى ساعه استجابه انا لو
سالتني اليوم كيف كنت تعمل بهذه الاعمال
الثلاثه اقول لك لا ادري كيف كنت اعمل هذا
توفيق من الله واذا وصلت الى النجاح الذي
كنت ترجوه
فيجب ان توقن اولا ان هذا توفيق من
الله اولا وقبل كل شيء هذا توفيق من الله
نعم بسبب جهدك بسبب صبرك وعناء نعم بسبب
دعاء والديك وحامك نعم لكن هو توفيق من
الله لا تقل كما
قال قارون انما اوتيته على علم عندي
لان عاقبته كما قال الله فخسفنا به وبداره
الارض الله هو المتفضل عليك وما فعلته هي
اسباب الصبر يعلمك ان تاخذ بالاسباب اذا
اردت ان تصل الى النجاح خذ بالاسباب اذا
اردت ان تنجح في دراستك
فذاكرة توفيق على الله كثير من الناس لا
ياخذون
بالاسباب الله سبحانه وتعالى يعلمنا في
قصه مريم عليها السلام وهزي اليك بجذع
النخله تساقط عليك رطبا جني اليس الله
بقادر على ان ينزل الرطب على مريم من غير
ان تهزه نعم ولكن اراد ان يعلمنا ولهذا
قال بعض الشعراء الم ترى ان الله قال
لمريم وهزي اليك الجذع يا الساقط الرط
ولو شاء ان تجنيه من غير هزه جنته ولكن كل
رزق له سبب عليك ان تاخذ
بالاسباب خذ بالاسباب واترك الامر لله ان
اخفقت فلا
تنكسر حاول مره اخرى حاول مره ثالثه فان
لم تستطع بعد تكرار المحاولات فاعلم ان
الله لم يقدر لك ذلك الامر
عندئذ عليك ان تبحث في
داخلك عن مواطن
القوه بما تمتاز انت من مواطن القوه فربما
قدر لك ان تنجح في سياق اخر غير هذا
السياق
بالصبر
بالتحمل بتنظيم الوقت بترتيب الاولويات
يحصل الانسان على ما يريد بقدر
الكد الكد تكتسب المعالي ومن طلب العلى
سهر الليالي ومن طلب العلى من غير كد اضاع
العمر في طلب
المحالي طيب الله اوقاتكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
وبركاته